how's it going friends family [ __ ]
you know I'm talking about
I don't welcome back to South Park and
gay this is my [ __ ] show nook anyway
welcome and yeah
so in the last episode we do you want to
[ __ ] with me and think so oh I got a new
message how the [ __ ] does he even
message I keep having the same dream I'm
sitting in a hot tub and keep getting a
little warmer then I wake up covered in
carob pocket huh I'm just saying so in
this episode we're gonna do the over
Chioggia request from Stan so let's do
that travel to Mars residents in
prepared to battle with Stan against the
evil shield sounds wonderful
can't wait this might be better Stan
we're here and I was somewhere more
interesting so easy telling me to change
to Stan let's do that then there we go
okay cool
nothing can prepare you for this battle
if I die tell the guys I fought bravely
what have you didn't I also solved the
audio problem hopefully finally I'm so
pissed off at that the [ __ ] is this
sans room where is this [ __ ] so this is
my room
nice figure action figure it looks like
me except a little little less and
myself what is this you are cordially
invited to the annual blood orgy what
what else have we got here can't believe
you know check the Stan's room before
oh yeah the guitar episode coming out
what never coming out who's not coming
out of the closet
never coming out Tom Cruise come out of
the closet Tom damn it Tom Cruise okay I
had picked up his eye Underpants y'know
and that side is where my parents leap
and across from that is the Cave of the
she ogre yeah let's stick where your
parents sleep first no I never got your
days are numbered she ogre I can oh yeah
yeah all right
this is this shitstorm
ha
nice more hahahaha
[ __ ] yeah best attack ever my phone
again and I shall bring just a Swifter
yet okay out of my room turn up
I want my iPhone I want got my guys out
- you ogre Slayer I'm glad to call you
friend oh you're welcome
oh it's a fine live we're here it's
goddamn friend that was it oh yeah yeah
okay so now if you remember the map you
can just talk to me
what is he won the shield ears Nomura Oh
Elvis can okay
alright everyone liked it right away
apparently let's find a quick station
whatever little [ __ ] new quest defeat
man what was it all of a sudden I told
you man bear pig was out there he's
attacking the church now but I had to go
ah goddamnit Oh goddamn allegory I
thought it was dead I thought for sure
he was dead I hate outdoor Al Gore's the
worst alright can't you keep a secret
I know my other okay ah Rangers do not
fear death [ __ ] really
you ain't no manbearpig [ __ ] my
circumcised your dick out okay I'm at
damage though
[ __ ] you Al Gore let's mark him oh
that's a defense down that's pretty good
actually
okay so now we use our super attack way
of the sword such a badass attack I like
that you didn't keep all of them comic
all oh oh
Cartman is a lot [ __ ] better though
I'm just saying oh oh [ __ ] oh damn that
damaged stuff no gore oh you almost died
finish em I'll go you piece of [ __ ] Oh
gore you finally beat up know you're Al
Gore Oh from this [ __ ] manbearpig
cloth that's that's not bad USB Drive I
want to shake him you know
okay but you know we should find Jesus
let's find Jesus new message from mr.
Hankey hell yeah
don't forget Christmas is right around
the corner
not really the Lord is with you my son
except for bossfights awesome so you
literally just come back but you can
only use it like once a day on whatever
but Jesus is pretty badass so it's okay
now finally we can go through the forest
the map or whatever Stan's room you bros
told me that it it will take us to the
place that we need to go first we have
to fart on these let's do it it's
convenient that's what it is okay let's
see if I remember I don't remember
okay it was right here before I should
dogs down right and then oh god I want
to fight you
the [ __ ] are you gonna win can we skip
this yes Oh for [ __ ] sake
[Music]
all right I'm using [ __ ] Jesus on
these [ __ ] God Jesus lock and load
goddamnit fat-ass you can wake up that
Cottman my nipples I hear my crab
nipples okay so write up and then ride
down and then right you go that way and
then then down and then right please
[ __ ] work yes
oh my god ah thank God all right where's
this [ __ ] she yogurt oh no it's you
look at ya a new kids have a so safe
yeah if you want your soul say oh you
got to do is accept the one truth Lord
is your personal Saviour and renounce
all the others it's all sides ah have
you watch this episode again I think
this is one of us [ __ ] up episodes so
I don't think I want them on my bad side
[Music]
god damn I'm so popular good will come
the end update when our Dark Master will
boil the oceans and lay siege to the
gates of heaven good meeting you guys oh
my go
how about go the [ __ ] out of here I
think that we'll be at two for southpark
a lot of ubirr want me to move on to the
next game so that's what we're gonna do
I've been working on another project
this week so that's why I've been
keeping this series going in the
meanwhile it's a quick video that I've
been working on but hopefully that will
be up soon but for now that's it for
South Park I had a lot of fun with this
game so I wanted really again just thank
you both for watching it because without
you it wouldn't be possible so there you
go yeah let me know what you want to see
me play in the comments and I'll check
it out and I'm in that a double today
we're feeling frisky huh hope you have a
great [ __ ] week and I hope you don't
kiss anybody so that I'd said that only
cause it rhymed all right
these are my friends hat and if you want
them my link in the description
okay now I said it